Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Denise RQ
Hace 3500 años en Egipto,
un noble faraón fue víctima
de un ataque violento.
Pero el ataque no fue físico.
Este faraón
había muerto hacía 20 años.
El ataque fue histórico,
un acto de "damnatio memoriae",
la condenación de la memoria.
Alguien destruyó sus estatuas,
e intentó borrar de la historia
con un cincel su nombre e imagen.
¿Quién era este faraón
y qué había detrás del ataque?
Esta es la clave:
el faraón Hatshepsut era mujer.
En el curso normal de las cosas,
nunca debería haber sido faraón.
Aunque era legal y las mujeres
podían ser monarcas,
perturbaba algunas
creencias esenciales egipcias.
Primero, el faraón era conocido
como la encarnación viviente
del dios masculino Horus.
Segundo, perturbar
la tradición patriarcal,
era un serio desafío al Maat,
palabra para "verdad" que expresaba
creencia en el orden y la justicia,
vital para los egipcios.
Hatshepsut quizá trató
de adaptarse a esta creencia
mediante la relación entre orden
y patriarcado a través de sus títulos.
Tomó el nombre Maatkare,
y a veces se refería a sí misma
como Hatshepsu, con terminación
de palabra masculina.
Pero, al parecer, estos esfuerzos
no convencieron a todos,
y quizá alguien borró
la imagen de Hatshepsut
para que el mundo olvidara
la perturbación al Maat,
y Egipto recuperara
el equilibrio otra vez.
Hatshepsut, por otra parte,
no era la heredera legítima al trono,
sino una regente, una especie
de co-monarca sustituta.
La realeza egipcia tradicionalmente
pasaba de padres a hijos.
Pasó de Tutmosis I
a su hijo Tutmosis II,
el marido de Hatshepsut.
Debería haber pasado de Tutmosis II
directamente a su hijo Tutmosis III,
pero Tutmosis III era un niño pequeño
cuando murió su padre.
Hatshepsut, la primera esposa
y viuda del difunto faraón,
se autoproclamó
como regente de su hijastro,
pero terminó gobernando junto a él
como faraón de pleno derecho.
Quizá Tutmosis III se enojó por esto.
Quizá fue él quien
borró las imágenes.
También es posible que alguien
quisiera deshonrar a Hatshepsut
por ser mala faraona.
Pero la evidencia sugiere
que era bastante buena.
Cumplió con competencia los roles
administrativos tradicionales.
Fue una gran constructora.
Su templo funerario, Djeser-Djeseru,
fue un fenómeno arquitectónico
para la época
y todavía es admirado hoy.
Mejoró la economía de Egipto,
dirigiendo una misión comercial
muy exitosa a la lejana tierra de Punt.
Tenía fuertes conexiones religiosas.
Incluso afirmaba ser hija
del dios Amón.
Y tuvo una exitosa carrera militar,
con una campaña nubia,
y sostuvo que luchó junto
a sus soldados en batalla.
Por supuesto, tenemos que tener
cuidado al evaluar el éxito
de la carrera de Hatshepsut,
ya que la mayoría de la evidencia
fue escrita por la propia Hatshepsut.
Cuenta su propia historia
en imágenes y por escrito
en los muros de su templo funerario
y en la capilla roja
que construyó para Amón.
Entonces, ¿quién cometió los crímenes
contra la memoria de Hatshepsut?
El sospechoso más popular es su hijastro,
sobrino y co-gobernante, Tutmosis III.
¿Lo hizo por ira dado
que ella le robó el trono?
Es poco probable ya
que el daño no se hizo
hasta 20 años después
de la muerte de Hatshepsut.
Es mucho tiempo para quedarse enojado
y luego actuar por rabia.
Quizá Tutmosis III quiso hacer que
su propio reinado pareciera más fuerte.
Pero es más probable que él
u otra persona borrase las imágenes
para que la gente olvidara que una mujer
alguna vez ocupó el trono egipcio.
Esta anomalía de género simplemente
era una amenaza muy grande al Maat
y debía ser borrada de la historia.
Felizmente, los antiguos censores
no eran tan minuciosos.
Se conservan bastantes pruebas
que nos permiten reconstruir lo que pasó
así que ahora puede contarse la historia
de esta mujer poderosa y única.